one of the weirdest things that I
experience on a daily basis is that my
views are considered controversial I
find this a hilarious reflection on how
crazy our society has become
I want Mass teachers to teach maths
history teachers to teach History
Literature teachers to educate children
about the best writers poets and
playwrights I want the police to
investigate actual crimes like rape
burglary stabbings muggings not paint
their cars rainbow colors and police
jokes banter and WhatsApp groups and
offensive tweets I want the media to
tell me the facts of what is going on
and let me decide what to think about it
if I want a journalist opinion which I
mostly don't I'll read opinion columns
just tell me what's happening I want
Banks to provide Bank Services ice cream
makers to make ice cream and raise a
company to make razors I want
transnational corporations to pay their
taxes I don't want them to tell me what
to think I don't need a moral lecture
from Mr Burns of The Simpsons I want
doctors to help me choose the best
treatment for me and my family not
enforce a one-size-fits-all solution
only because of government dictats I
don't need scary advertising campaigns
that misrepresent the threat to
encourage me to look after my health I
want the military to spend every waking
moment working to get better at killing
people who want to kill me my family and
my fellow citizens I don't care how
diverse Progressive or inclusive they
are and I'm outright hostile to this if
it affects their performance I want the
legal system to reward productive lawful
behavior and to deter unproductive
unlawful Behavior I want Psychopathic
evil and dangerous people to be kept
away from me my family and my fellow
law-abiding citizens I want politicians
to implement the Democratic wishes of
the people of this country even when I
don't personally agree with those wishes
if the majority of my fellow citizens
vote for something I don't agree with I
can campaign against this while
accepting the Democratic outcome I want
the government to interfere in my life
as little as possible while recognizing
the government is necessary I want to
pay as little taxes lawfully possible
but enough to fund the things only
government can do I want an absolute
meritocracy hard work dedication and
talent must always be rewarded if you're
lazy if you don't apply yourself if you
aren't contribute you don't deserve to
be rewarded as much as the people who
work their asses off I want people to be
treated equally not is inferior or
Superior just equal there's no such
thing as positive discrimination just
discrimination that's it that's what
makes me controversial
by the way if you enjoy these monologues
you should know that they go out as a
sub stag first Sometimes weeks ahead of
time so if you want to get them head on
over to my sub stack and become a
subscriber
[Music]